Dear Fellow Scholars, this is Two Minute Papers
with Károly Zsolnai-Fehér.
We have recently witnessed the emergence of
neural network-based techniques that are able
to synthesize all sorts of images.
Our previous episode was about NVIDIA's algorithm
that created high resolution images of imaginary
celebrities that was a really cool application
of Generative Adversarial Networks.
This architecture means that we have a pair
of neural networks, one that learns to generate
new images, and the other learns to tell a
fake image from a real one.
As they compete against each other, they get
better and better without any human interaction.
So we can clearly use them to create 2D images,
but why stop there?
Why not use this technique, for instance,
to create assets for digital media?
So instead of 2D images, let's try to adapt
these networks to generate high-resolution
3D models of terrains that we can use to populate
a virtual world.
Both computer games and the motion picture
industry could benefit greatly from such a
tool.
This process is typically done via procedural
generation, which is basically a sort of guided
random terrain generation.
Here, we can have a more direct effect on
the output without putting in tens of hours
of work to get the job done.
In the first training step, this technique
learns how an image of a terrain corresponds
to input drawings.
Then, we will be able to sketch a draft of
a landscape with rivers, ridges, valleys and
the algorithm will output a high quality model
of the terrain itself.
During this process, we can have a look at
the current output and refine our drawings
in the meantime, leading to a super efficient
process where we can go from a thought to
a high-quality final result within a few seconds
without being bogged down with the technical
details.
What's more, it can also not only deal with
erased subregions, but it can also automatically
fill them with sensible information to save
time for us.
What an outstanding convenience feature!
And, the algorithm can also perform physical
manipulations like erosion to the final results.
After the training for the erosion step is
done, the computational cost is practically
zero, for instance, running an erosion simulator
on this piece of data would take around 40
seconds, where the neural network can do it
in 25 milliseconds.
The full simulation would almost be a minute,
where the network can mimic its results practically
instantaneously.
A limitation of this technique is that if
the input is too sparse, unpleasant grid artifacts
may appear.
There are tons of more cool features in the
paper, make sure to have a look, as always,
it is available in the video description.
This is a really well thought out and well-presented
work that I expect to be a true powerhouse
for terrain authoring in the future.
And, in the meantime, we have reached a hundred
thousand subscribers.
A hundred thousand Fellow Scholars.
Wow.
This is absolutely amazing and honestly I
never thought that this would ever happen.
So, happy paperversary, thank you very much
for coming along on this journey of science
and I am very happy to see that the series
brings joy and learning to more people than
ever.
Thanks for watching and for your generous
support, and I'll see you next time!